13 uhr cassandra ihn geschrieben ich
muss euch mitten ins studio
pfefferspray
hier ist meine unterwäsche drin rückhalt
wenn du dich traust du herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video leute
sitzen wollte zusammen mit kelly und ich
bin so übertrieben brülle ich aufgeregt
wir haben nämlich das krasseste mega
ultra projekt er war klar ich habe das
ja schon oft ins tal und im letzten
videos geht dieser wir werden nämlich
unser leben tauschen
und das ganze ohne fähig und irgendwas
sondern wirklich 24 stunden unser leben
tauschen ja was wir eigentlich machen
würden den ganzen tag wir sind kann bei
mir in der wohnung
kelly hat ihren koffer dabei besteht
hier vorne und ich habe meinen koffer
gepackt und sie tauschen gleich und so
schlüssel und dann bin ich für 24
stunden waren raus aus meinem eigenen
leben
aber bevor wir irgendwie weiter reden
ihr müsst unbedingt wirklich unbedingt
unbedingt kenntnis kanals alles abdecken
nachdem ihr dieses video geschaut habe
das wird der erste mengen der
beschreibung sein dann sind sie einfach
wie sie sich in meiner wohnung umschaut
und gesät sachen die ihr davor noch nie
gesehen hat und es wird einfach komplett
crazy und gerade nützlich die krähe
ja ich meine koffer oder auch zugedachte
was machen
sie haben uns auf jeden fall beide
gegenseitig so ein tag ist plan getreten
damit wir auch nen ist nun gegenseitig
restaurant wann zu tun das ist sowieso
nur leicht um 13 uhr seine erste liebe
lust und wir haben 12 und münchen genau
das heißt ich muss vielleicht wird das
uns das ganze angehen wenn ich sage wir
müssen schlüssel kaufen und es wird
übrigens eine mehrteilige serie das
heißt wir machen nicht nur einen teil
sondern es gibt mindestens zweiten
vielleicht im dritten teil
nachdem die gruppe ist ankommen dass
ismaik sein kommentar das ist mein
schlüsselbund ein ich muss gar nicht
wissen das ist bereit ja wir tauschen
video nochmal genau konnte ich hab noch
nie den schlüssel von niemandem sonst
also wirklich so den schlüsselbund sich
als trainer eigentlich nicht aus ich
glaube ich habe jetzt schon bei dessen
dass der aus betrifft ist es ist jetzt
meine wohnung
damit sagen viel spaß in meinem leben
ich geb dir doch die zeit und ich denke
ist von kathrin zettel mit meinem
tagesablauf und dann muss ich mich auch
schon auf den weg machen zum ersten
termin um 13 uhr ok freunde wieder habe
ich schon nicht mehr eine kamera so ein
blog perspektive gehalten ich bin ohne
wird es komplett aufgeregt ich bin ja
jetzt mal in meinem schlafzimmer hier
ist mein koffer da muss ich noch ein
zwei sachen reinschmeißen und ich öffne
jetzt mal mit euch zusammen den brief
den kelly mehr geschrieben hat kann man
perspektive sitzt auf jeden fall
tagesplan 13 uhr beauty time palmstraße
8 ist auf deinen namen die wissen
bescheid aber fragt trotzdem noch mal
wegen film beauty time was war okay das
ist der erste tagesblatt ich gucke jetzt
erstmal nicht weiter rein damit ich noch
ein bisschen überraschung habe ich muss
jetzt in einer halben stunde bei der
adresse sein und habe anscheinend duty
teil
das ist so außerhalb der komfortzone was
wir hier machen aber wir machen uns also
ich gehe es aus meiner wohnung raus und
dann heißt es erst mal tschüss für 24
stunden bin ich wahrscheinlich morgen so
um 13 uhr wieder in meiner eigenen
wohnung bis dahin band kelly hier los
geht's wir haben uns gerade
verabschiedet ich stehe in einem aufzug
und mache mich jetzt auf dem weg zum
ersten termin
kelly ist in meiner wohnung ich bin weg
sie kann alles anschauen
du hast geht's
ok ich sitze ich hier rum und vertreiben
noch ein bisschen die zeit in 18 minuten
ist mein erster termin ich muss auch
gleich weiter ich habe schon
hingeschrieben dem freund von kelly der
auch musik macht und so ich musste mich
mit ihm ins studio habe ich erfahren und
ich habe geschrieben von kelly hast du
auch meine wir gespannt was du dir hast
du über dieses projekt schreibt marcks
geld bin auch gespannt erscheint weiß
nicht mehr was wir machen ich werde
wahrscheinlich singen müssen
das heißt wenn nämlich singen hören
wollt dann bleibt dran schaut die
nächsten videos bis jetzt immer noch weh
und jati adresse eingegeben die kerle
mir aufgeschrieben hat und guck mal was
bei google kommt wenn man das ein gibt
max max waxing studio wo mein gott als
ob ich jetzt nicht wachsen lassen muss
ich gehe jetzt erstmal hin und
hoffentlich bieten die noch irgendwas
anderes an aber fünf minuten zu fuß dann
bin ich pünktlich freunde ich muss jetzt
einfach mal anrufen und fragen wegen
waxing ob das jetzt hoffe ich wirklich
jetzt geweckt werde weil ich glaube das
tut doch übertrieben okay sie geht nicht
rein weil meine sprach wm ok ich hab'
hat die adresse die mir aufgeschrieben
hast bei google maps eingegeben und dann
kommt einfach waxing studio es ernst
werde ich jetzt geht er jetzt hin und
mein gott ich muss das jetzt durchziehen
kelly hat geantwortet ich jetzt sagen
augen zu und durch
ich bin und ich glaube ich muss mir noch
überlegen wie ich mich wachsen lasse oh
mein gott altert hätte nicht gedacht
dass das mal machen in meinem
nach vorne bis den laden möglich
zunächst muss die gehäuse
ich hoffe übrigens dass das nicht so
schlimm ist dass ich immer switche
zwischen handy und großer kamera aber
dies hat er schwer auszupacken immer aus
dem rucksack und deshalb wächst ich das
einfach so ich muss jetzt rein die nicht
frage erstmalig filmen kann und er wird
es ja dann sehen sonst sehen wir uns
gleich wieder komplett oder wie ich habe
so eine krasse bein waren okay das
musste ich mir noch mal gut vision kopf
gehen lassen vielleicht würde ich ja
auch bewussten auf längst oder sowas
wenn es gibt vielleicht mehr weh aber
ich will keine glatten beine
okay wir überlegen uns das noch mal okay
schon mal danke schön an sich kelly an
der stelle also kelly hat für mich eine
komplett gebucht
oh mein gott also ich kann euch denn wir
zeigen die brav meine beine sind noch
nicht gedacht jetzt aus meinem video
sage aber ich werde wahrscheinlich
wechseln auch bewusst weil keine ahnung
das dauert dann fünf jahre was meine
beinharter nachgewachsen sind und ja
herr leute hier setzt
und kriegt meine brust gewachst ist
vielleicht auch eine gute entscheidung
aber bei der tut mir leid kann die beine
hätte ich nicht übers herz gebracht weil
ich zeige euch dass man jetzt ganz gut
das sind meine beine und ich habe mein
leben lang schon mega viel bein habe und
wenn ich jetzt einfach so ein glatte hot
dogs als beide hätten und ich glaube ich
damit nicht klarkommen deshalb machen
wir die brust mal gucken wie viel ich da
drin jetzt gleich filme ich durfte
glücklicherweise meine kamera hier raus
sondern filme zuweisung fahrt auf was
ich mich eingelassen weil ich habe kelly
eigentlich nichts gemein ist gegeben und
sie macht einfach waxing vielleicht muss
ich meinen freunden die später mit dem
auto fahren auch irgendwie sagen dass
die sie einmal so schreien sollen dass
sie sich bald erschreckt oder so als
mache diese sind nicht das ist schon mal
der heißt hier liebe hinfällt
das sieht schmerzhaft aus oder dass
irgendwas macht glück habe ich nicht so
schlimme haare sind ja voll mit schienen
aufleben vielleicht kann ich ja noch nie
oberkörperfrei gezeigt ich wurde gerade
erst mal gepudert die sache ist wir
machen das ganze ist das heißt dass hier
mehr heißt es fühlt sich echt gut dann
vielleicht mache ich das jetzt immer ich
frage mich wie schlimm das wirklich sein
kann die schmerzen ich meinen jeder sagt
ja das ist das immer so
gibt es fünf darauf weisen kann wenn man
sich stirbt verschmerzen so was das ist
so das motto von ihrem laden aber wenn
ich aber beim haare gemacht hätte dass
wir so ist das schon der erste ok piste
runter oli jou jou jou jye zum glück
nicht so krasse leute erst mal ein
bisschen in ruhe gleich wieder das war
da einfach richtig groß und das sind
einfach meine haare
wo gott ich habe somit der fünf prozent
geschafft da geht es nicht dass mein
körper ich die aus den krebs der so
flecken weise noch ein paar haben mann
ist scheiße ich kann hier gleich mein
foto zeigen von kelly damit beweist wenn
du es nicht einmal richtig leiden lassen
muss wenn sie hier vorbeikommt okay ich
hoffe am schwitzen
naja vielleicht hat es geschafft ich
habe es jetzt einfach ausgesessen ist so
krass diese kannte hier oben oder das
ist der letzte streifen abgezogen wird
wissenschaft ist auch wegen seiner
erfahrung gewesen so sich jetzt aus dass
es einfach keine haare mehr aktuell
ich habe gerade mal kellys ist dafür 28
ich habs gerade kellys instagram kommen
wir gezeigt dass sie genau wissen sie ja
beim nächsten mal wechseln richtig
leiden muss damit hat sie eine
geschäftsaufgabe gerne und außerdem guck
dir gerne nochmal vorbei der laden heißt
max max und ich wurde noch nie so gut
wächst also danke schön
und dann kann die anklage und dann geht
es jetzt weiter
und ich treffe ich eine nike ok kleine
veränderungen eigentlich wollte ich mich
um
sollte ich sollte ich mich nicht wollte
ich mich um 14 uhr mit dem eintreffen
der kann aber erst im 16 das heißt ich
feiere kelly in die wohnung oder in
meine wohnung meine ich natürlich in
koppl die waren ja unseren tagesablauf
von treffen und hier bin ich am telefon
willkommen im hrt zwerg und er zeigt mir
mittelfinger erstmal außer atem von der
treppe aber ohne witz dieses ganze
projekt fire so kennt man richtig schön
aufgeräumt und alle fenster und über ein
zu kleines hätte wir entdecken jetzt
gleich zusammen alles ich hole die
richtige kamera raus und wir gucken uns
das an
okay leute ich hab jetzt auf die große
kamera gewechselt ich habe mich nicht
viel bewegt und wir gucken uns jetzt
zusammen alles gemeinsam an ich bin mir
sicher wir werden die ein oder andere
sache
decken und kelly nun kannst kann es gift
darauf nehmen dass ich keine rücksicht
nehmen werde nicht nach dem was du mir
gerade angetan hast also leute hier ist
der eingangsbereich ich weiß ja immer so
eine richtige wut hochgeladen hat die
ihre schuhe und verschiedene sachen wir
haben sie schon mal kurzen facetime das
könnt ihr in kellys video sehen und
haben über meine waxing behandlung
gesprochen sie hat auch schon eine kappe
von mir auf und wird jetzt gleich in die
uni gehen dass wir schon mal cool der
zwerg hier habe ich sehr gefeiert wie
kommen und mittelfinger das hier sehr
nice fahndungsplakaten sirius black und
von harry potter das ist ja eine
gemeinsamkeit verlieren credit dass wir
beide kräfte harry potter fans sind und
ja hier ist mein badezimmer ist sagt
kelis aber natürlich ist es meins weil
ihr wisst ja das ist meine wohnung da
ist mein komischer großen ding das
benutze ich regelmäßig damit meine haut
besser wird das funktioniert so man
nimmt das kriegt man so ok der iss
kaputt der wird bald repariert
bestimmtem eine toilette mal war man ja
auf jeden fall muss man der
waschmaschine
es ist lustig jetzt ein altbau duschen
sind der horror die temperatur ist denke
ich perfekt eingestellt muss nur auf
links drehen
kenny hat gar keiner duschkabine sondern
mit duschwanne ja bei mir gibt es beides
carina ich schon kenne ich meine wohnung
findet also kellys wohnung ist richtig
cool eingerichtet dann kommt hier so
rein das ist so richtig so volker sie
und saßen dann die harry potter plakate
feiere ich okay das ist das badezimmer
ich gebe euch einfach eine wucht und wie
sollte es auch anders sein wo die hier
ist mein schlafzimmer ich war noch nie
bei kelly im schlafzimmer ich heute
nacht werde ich hier scheinbar schlafen
okay dein spiegel noch mehr harry potter
hier das ist immer gut und hier mache
ich dann immer mein outfit foster kelli
schreibe ich dann mal drunter bitte nike
seine klamotten mitbringen ich treffe
mich ja gleich noch mit mikey na ja da
sind meine gute sache was auch immer ich
noch mal ran gut die haare habe mir auf
empfehlung von freddy ein matratzen
tochter gekauft weiß noch nicht ob ich
gut finde
ach das ist eine boxspringbetten
bockspringen wird und hier ist ein top
ich glaube dass es richtig gemütlich ich
kann dir gerne bescheid sagen ok hat so
voll die dünne decke ich habe schon eine
richtig fette daunendecke noch aber sind
auch trotzdem zu acht grad draußen was
als meine feinde dich im schlaf
angreifen pfefferspray
rapper casper besser kennt ihn nicht im
schlaf angreifen sonst kommt das
pfefferspray sei es ist ja hier schminke
ich mich dann meistens da sage ich dann
zum beispiel so sachen make-up von estée
lauder kann ich sehr empfehlen da bin
ich vielleicht mehr fachleute
ok ich weiß nicht ob es neben werde aber
könnte man was hier steht warning hier
ist meine unterwäsche drin rückhalt wenn
du dich traust aber das wird immer
zwischen uns stehen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich diesen
schrank öffnen sollte ich werde auf
jeden fall nicht jetzt gleich machen ich
glaube ich spüre es wenn ihr mir jetzt
ein leicht auf dieses video weit dann
könnte ich ihn höchstwahrscheinlich
öffnen deshalb macht es mal generell
dieses knorrige battle und so was ist
immer blöd aber ich wollte wirklich
gerne sagen 65 prozent der leute die
meine videos schauen haben einen kanal
nicht abonniert und das ist eigentlich
schade
wollt ihr das nicht ändern wenn du
gerade mal wie du schaust das cool
finden ist und weinen kanal nicht
abonniert hast stadt abonnieren doch
einfach weil
dann kannst du mehr von solchen coolen
videos sehen und ich bemühe mich auf
jeden fall immer so coole video ideen zu
finden das ist jetzt schon echt ein
special project aber glaube es lohnt
sich deshalb armee hat schlafzimmer ist
abgehakt gucken wir mal weiter
hier geht es weiter hier können in die
küche das eigentlich voll cool kelly
hast sondern offene wohnküche ist ja
eine dachgeschosswohnung also so eine
maisonette das heißt da ist noch eine
weitere etage entsteht hier einfach so
fünf meter unter der decke ich kann mal
gucken gibt es was im kühlschrank zu
essen
oha natürlich richtig schlecht hier ist
so ein helfen fitness brownie lecker sie
hat einfach einen eigenen brownie
gebacken und in meinem kühlschrank gibt
es nur so müll und saucen ketchup und so
weiter was das projekt rohkost das ist
weil wir auch ein hauptnahrungsmittel
von berlin ist das remoulade diese zwei
liter cola und nebendran fast mayonnaise
mayonnaise ist wichtig dass die kirche
so könne es nicht gereicht wenn mir
deine gefällt komme ich jeden tag vorbei
das ist richtig cool kelly hat er so ein
regal mit so sachen die sie ausstellt
und 100 euro scheint hier ist einfach
harry potter regal die schreibt dazu
muss ich nichts sagen oder der vierte
hedwig schokoladen frösche felix
polizist wo haben sie war bei harry
potter and the cursed das kommt jetzt
glaube ich auch nach deutschland
ein deutscher webvideo preis 2015 so was
gibt es in meiner wohnung definitiv
nicht dafür bin ich zu scheiße und
100.000 abonnenten play button den gibts
bei mir und hier draußen eigentlich
vollständig so ein kleiner balkon
ich finde es hier gut nach dem ersten
eindruck von deiner wohnung ich muss
zwar noch nach oben gehen aber nach dem
ersten eindruck könnte es gerne öfter
machen
ich werde natürlich noch die eine andere
sache entdecken und sie euch zeigen aber
gehen wir mal hier die treppe hoch und
hier oben war ich schon ein paar mal ich
meine
ja schon videos gedreht jetzt fällt es
mir wieder ein ich habe gerade auf den
zettel geschaut mit meiner tagesplan
dass sich ja auch später ins studio gehe
mit rahim hirschstetten zettel hier
kannst du ein bisschen üben bevor es
später ins studio geht ja ich zeige euch
mal das einzige lied was ich spielen
kann überall so harry potter märz und
was ist das für ein krankes gaming setup
ein heftiger gaming monitor mikrofon
nice zockt kelly schreibt mein konto ich
weiß ist einfach nicht obwohl wirkt
unser leben tauschen bin ich einfach
dumm und sie macht gaming videos das
wäre jetzt übertrieben peinlich und sie
hat einfach aus der wohnung richtig
perfekten blick auf den kölner dom hier
erzählt ein paar kostüme
ich meine das kennt glaube ich jeder
youtuber dass man irgendwo fliegen hat
den man mal für ein youtube-video
gebraucht hat habe ich glaube ich jetzt
das meiste in der wohnung wir hier schon
angeschaut falls du ein bisschen komfort
aus harry potter bücher und dvds gibt es
aber auch im team google player app
google player und itunes ich glaube hier
kann ich mich gut wohl fühlen schreibt
gerne mal die kommentare wieder so das
video bisher findet ich meine es
wirklich eine ganz neue sache wirklich
glaube ich auf youtube ich kann es euch
nun auch noch einmal allen sagen schaut
alle bei kelly vorbei weil ich meine
immerhin könnt ihr dann meine wohnung
offene art und weise sehen wir sie noch
nie gesehen habt lasst sie auch gerne
ein abo da ich bin zwar der kleinere von
uns bleiben aber wir können jetzt zeigen
dass wir auch jede menge power haben und
schreibt einfach mal ein kommentar lesen
dass der bisschen liebe da schreibt er
schreibt er ein like schreibt jan
lackmann und lasst den abo da das wird
sie bestimmt freuen
ansonsten ich glaube ich dir jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen manchmal die kamera
kurz aus ein bisschen runter
okay leute ich bin jetzt ein bisschen
angekommen hat man was getrunken ich
werde gleich nochmal den brownie von
kelly probieren und ich muss sie ihre
wäsche aufhängen
meine ich meine wäsche jetzt sozusagen
viele maschinen ist nämlich fertig war
echt selbstgebackene brown ist zu hart
kassel niemals würde ich selbst backen
der sieht richtig gut aus
naja leute dann probieren wir mal
ehrlich kuchen wenn wir wirklich so ein
fitness kuchen ist also wenn er nicht so
viel kalorien hat und
sonst war es der schmecken die fast
normal abbuchen passiert habe ich erst
mal mittagessen war um 1440 ich habe
nicht mal gefrühstückt die erst gerade
zum ersten mal irgendwas nicht glaube
ich verdrücken bei diesem kuchen und
somit etwas zum essen und dann rechne
ich auch gleich schon mit nike aber
davor muss noch die wäsche aufhängen
[Musik]
das geht jetzt nicht weiß und dass ich
das prinzen macht zum prinzen also dann
wollen wir uns treffen wir haben jetzt
14 uhr okay ich würde auch sagen dass
ich hier fertig bin
in 35 minuten alles klar machen wir das
so
[Musik]